[Music]
foreign
so in the last lecture I showed you that
in addition to having Matrix systems of
equations x dot equals ax where you get
stable eigenvalues things like e to the
minus Lambda t or unstable eigenvalues
things like e to the plus Lambda T there
are also these kind of strange cases
where you can get this it's almost like
an in-between type Dynamics where it
looks initially unstable but then
eventually the trajectory becomes stable
this is called transient energy growth
and then eventually it goes into stable
Decay and this is going to be a
phenomena we see in Matrix systems of
equations where the a matrix is
so-called non-normal meaning that a
transpose a does not equal to a times a
transpose and this is a very very common
feature in lots of dynamical systems so
things like fluid flows highly sheared
fluid flows where you have
literally High Shear in in that flu it
like like a pipe flow through a pipe
where you have much faster flow in the
middle and slower flow on the outside
that is going to be a sheer dominated
flow and the a matrix for the linearized
system are is going to be non-normal and
give rise to this kind of interesting uh
this interesting Behavior here and I'm
going to claim that just like this is
governed by e to the Lambda T and this
is governed by e to the Lambda t for a
stable or an unstable Lambda here the
Dynamics are going to be dominated by a
term that looks like T times e to the
Lambda t uh and that comes up when you
have a matrix of this form here where
you have a repeated eigenvalue so in the
past what I've shown you is Matrix
matrices a where you have distinct
eigenvalues maybe one's real uh maybe
maybe one's positive and one's negative
or two are real and just you know
positive and distinct to our negative
and distinct or to our complex
conjugates here in this case we have
eigenvalues that are the same both of
the eigenvalues of this system are are
Lambda so they're not distinct anymore
and in this case we have this
interesting transient energy growth so
I'm going to show you how to derive that
today
and specifically what we're going to do
is we're going to compute
e to the Matrix a t because we know that
that's going to be the solution of this
system is you know X of T equals e to
the a t times x naught so we want to
compute The Matrix exponential
and I'm going to claim that this is e to
the Lambda t
e to the Lambda t on the diagonals but
then on the off diagonal we're going to
get a t e to the Lambda T term and this
t e to the Lambda T off diagonal is
going to mean that certain parts of my
state are going to get Amplified in this
transient growth before they eventually
become stable and you can literally in
python or Matlab plot t e to the Lambda
t for a negative Lambda and convince
yourself that this is exactly the shape
you get these are called secular terms
and they're very very important
so to demonstrate that you get this kind
of Dynamics I'm just going to kind of
walk you through how to take this Matrix
exponential there is a linear algebra
kind of fact that I think you should
know that'll be helpful for proving this
you could call it a proposition if you
like so a proposition
it's fairly modest if
we have S times T equals T times s these
are for two matrices s and t and this is
not true in general
not true in general
but if it is true then
oh that's not a then
sorry that's a terrible H and I can't
abide it then
e to the S times T is our e to the S
Plus t
equals e to the s
times e to the T for for matrices s and
matrices t Okay so this is really
important if s times T equals T times s
then then this is true
um and so if you wanted to prove this
you could use the binomial theorem so to
prove
you would use the binomial theorem
binomial
theorem
and you would essentially compute S Plus
t to the power n equals it's going to be
a little bit of a mess it's going to be
n factorial summation
of J plus k equals n j plus k equals n
of s to the power J of t to the power K
Over J factorial K factorial and you
could essentially use this property and
of course if s times T equals T times s
then all of these products you can you
can flip them and if you write out the
um
The Matrix exponential and you plug in S
Plus T you're going to get you know
identity plus S Plus t plus S Plus t
squared plus S Plus T cubed and you're
going to need to use this expansion for
every single one of those terms and
you'll use this fact here so that all of
those terms you can flip s and t and
you'll get the the property that you're
looking for we're going to take that for
granted
that if we have this property then we
can break our Matrix exponential like
this if s and t were just scalar numbers
this would always be true but for
matrices this is not always true because
this is not always true in general
okay and so you can verify so you can
verify
um verify that our a matrix
which we're going to say is Lambda 0 0
Lambda that's going to be
uh s
plus 0 1 0 0 that's going to be t
you can verify that s times T
um
literally s times T is going to be zero
zero and then Lambda 0 S times T is zero
lambda zero zero and you could also
verify that t times a sorry T times s is
also going to be 0 0 lambda zero so this
also equals T times s
so this property uh holds and so that
means that
e to the S Plus T is going to equal e to
the S times e to the T
and so e to the Matrix a is just e to
the S Plus T So e to the Matrix a is
going to be e to the S part times e to
the T part okay
and e to the S is really really simple
so I'm going to switch colors again
um e to the s
is just uh e to the
maybe let's say e to the s t I should
put uh you know little put times in here
little vectors of time so e to the St is
going to be e to the Lambda t 0 0 e to
the Lambda t
and now all I have to compute is e to
the Big T T and that's also pretty easy
because remember
e to the big t uh times time is going to
equal you know identity plus Big T time
plus Big T times
squared over 2 factorial plus dot dot
dot dot
but here's where it gets kind of cool
this Matrix times itself
is zero so t squared is zero T cubed to
zero these are all zero
and so literally e to the big Matrix T
times time is just these two terms so
that's kind of cool it's literally uh uh
one
t 0 1. this is what e to the Big T T
looks like and so I can now I can take
um
you know this is going to be
e to the St
which is e to the Lambda t zero zero
zero times e to the Big T T which is 1 t
0 1.
and if I do the math I get that this is
you know e to the Lambda t
0
t e to the Lambda t
and
um
sorry this was supposed to be in need of
the Lambda T2 I messed up I messed up
sorry I bet you're screaming into your
TVs right now or your phones or your
iPads or
uh okay so sorry let's do that again one
zero times that is just e to the Lambda
t zero that's good T1 times this is t e
to the lambda zero Lambda T and one
times e to the Lambda t either Lambda t
so this just verifies that this
expression I wrote down is in fact what
you get when you compute this funky
Matrix exponential using this weird
proposition that I told you about okay
so that's kind of fun um this would
actually be a good homework you know you
could pause the video and you could work
out this expansion and actually prove
that if this is true then this is true
by using this property here in The
Matrix exponential that would be a good
like homework problem
um but if you take my word for that then
we can break a down into the sum of
these two matrices where it's easy to
compute e to the Matrix S and E to The
Matrix T either the Matrix S is
literally just you know it's a diagonal
matrix and this one's even easier
because it's it's Powers here it's
expansion it's Taylor series expansion
you know every Power t squared T cubed t
to the fourth is zero so all of these
die and I just have identity plus Big T
times time and then when I take and I
multiply those two matrices I get the
solution and it's specifically this term
here this secular term secular
term
that gives us all of these interesting
transient energy growth if you plot this
in python or in Matlab you'll see that
for short times the T term dominates
because the Taylor series of e is 1 plus
t plus t squared and so on and so forth
so for short times the T dominates and
this thing has a slope of t a slope of
one and then for longer times the e to
the minus t dominates and eventually it
dies out so this thing like literally
you know will eventually converge to the
e to the e to the Lambda T but for short
times it looks like like T
that's pretty cool
um okay good so
you could certainly compute the
eigenvalues and eigenvectors of this
thing that would be interesting too
um in fact I think I'm going to do that
for you maybe in the next lecture maybe
that's the next lecture I'm going to do
so in the next lecture what I'm going to
do is I'm going to actually compute the
eigenvalues and eigenvectors of this a
matrix in fact I'm going to show you how
to compute eigenvectors when you have
this kind of degeneracy or a repeated
eigenvalue and then we're going to talk
about you know in general for an a
matrix what are the types what are the
canonical building blocks of an a matrix
because I've shown you only a matrices
that are two by two but almost
everything I've shown you also applies
to three by three and four by four and
five by five and they're going to be
built out of these little building
blocks of you know based on the
eigenvalues if I have complex conjugate
pairs of eigenvalues or satellite values
I'm going to be able to build you know
my generic Solutions of my generic large
a matrices and sometimes I'm going to
have blocks that look like this these
are called Jordan blocks with repeated
eigenvalues and a little one up here and
that's going to tell me I'm definitely
going to have these secular terms and
I'm going to have this trans energy
growth okay so next time we're going to
look at the eigenvalues and eigenvectors
of this and then put that into the the
broader context of a matrices in general
what are all of the types of of Dynamics
I can get for any type of a matrix all
right that's coming up soon thank you
[Music]